o noite eu sou félix robatto robatto vou
falar sobre a minha carreira soube
construir uma carreira soube construir
um trabalho com música
quem sou eu sou farense robatto sou
músico sou pesquisador musical produtor
musical sempre trabalhei com música
desde garotinho eu já gostava de música
já gostava de guitarra né
era algo que sempre tinha sempre teve em
casa instrumentos e tal minha mãe sempre
gostou de música era cercado com
instrumentos e comecei a seguir isso
além da brincadeira pra minha vida né
e depois disso passei várias bandas na
adolescência eu com três anos de idade
entrei na primeira linha na minha
primeira banda profissional foi a banda
next uma banda baiana na época tinha
muito isso
a banda baiana que toca à formatura
ainda têm hoje em dia mas na época era
muito muito comum é assim a maioria das
bandas é assim e essa uma das bandas que
eu participasse pei orquestra de música
latina da ufpa
o bando origem a maioria de cantar
aquela música agora sou eu sou é um
laboratório móvel a pupunha e 60 e 70
mas vou contar um pouco como foi pra
chegar nessas paradas
olha essa banda que pode esperar marca
registrada esse louco aqui esse lado
aqui era eu
na época ela tinha pinta de paquito
é e quando passei no vestibular
passei no vestibular para música
licenciatura em música passei na uepa
que isso aí mudou muito a minha cabeça
nem quando entender é pá eu comecei a
conviver com outros músicos que não eram
necessariamente as músicas que tocaram
comigo nestas bandas músicos que tocavam
a mesma coisa que compartilhavam a mesma
cabeça da mesma idéia
eu entrei na universidade tinha músicos
é de rock de samba de músicos
evangélicos músicos eruditos e isso
mudou muito mexeu muito foi um impacto
muito grande
é na minha cabeça ver que tem um
universo muito grande e aquilo ali pode
influenciar muito tanto que influenciou
muito mesmo que já entrei lá já como
comecei a ter mais idéias para começar
levará adiante meu próprio e na uma
dessas idéias que eu tive na época da
uepa foi fazer uma pesquisa sobre
guitarrada abriu a inscrição do protesto
e uma bolsa de iniciação científica e eu
e mais dois amigos resolvemos pesquisar
a guitarrada já se ouvia falar um pouco
de guitarrada nessa época e era mais o
piloto batuque é um outro guitarrista
que já tinha feito um trabalho sobre
isso ea gente tem a gente quis pesquisar
mais se aprofunda mais e levar adiante e
durante essas pesquisas sobre guitarrada
sobre esse gênero instrumental paraense
de guitarra
surgiu essa banda o lá punha a mão
começou a passar mas só dá vontade de
tocar a guitarra de de gravar de compor
e foi assim que nasceu o la pupunha é
era uma banda formada por 16 músicos
cinco eram da universidade todos do
curso de música
é uma galera que ficava lá tocando
violão no corredor e cheio de idéias
também e quando pintou isso foi só o
estalo atlântico continuar
tá e nós gravamos dois discos a banda
começou em 24 terminou em 2010
exatamente quando o disco saiu depois
que a banda acabou porque sabe que o
disco vai para a fábrica a demora tem
todo aquele processo
a banda de 2004 a 2010
em 2008 nós somos o primeiro disco
alright penoso e 2013 depois que a banda
tinha acabado o disco voador que é um
disco que fala sobre aqueles que eles
caso jorge colares nos anos 70 sobre os
discos discos voadores chupa-chupa de
seta o disco bem humorado inclusive e da
pupunha antes várias histórias têm muita
história nem viajou muito é é uma época
que os festivais independentes estavam
bem aquecido de música independente
música alternativa
a gente pode circular por vários lugares
do brasil net quase todos os festivais
independentes do brasil onde foi alguns
no exterior
aí a gente vê a gente com 20 bandas na
época o irmão estava totalmente inativa
a gente tocando junto com eles a gente
foi desgastando ram ali embaixo a gente
com a banda de ordens para quem não
conhece a banda the jonas é uma banda
jovem guarda que nos anos 60 os beats
encontrado com eles e os beats pedir
autógrafo para eles
é aqui ver também dona ivone lara ali
tão boa ali está a galera chimbinha mexe
vieira aldo sena pessoas da guitarrada
também jayme katarro aqui no meio jogado
em cima de mim quebrou uma guitarra
é ali em cima tem uma uma cidadã menino
meio da gente a gaby amarantos isso em
2004 foi o primeiro primeira vez que ela
viajou assim pra fazer um show que a
banda que acompanhou ela foi lá pupunha
paralelamente enchem os projetos
paralelos não é que paralelamente né
o the vassos que era uma banda de surf
music sentiu sempre gostou de tocar sua
família que sempre foi uma influência
muito grande pra lá punha e era um trio
que formou em em 2007 e foi tocando
sempre que podia a gente tocava e depois
que lobo e acabou
do mesmo jeito que começou assim todo
mundo na universidade e tal cheio de
idéias chegou um momento que a galera
foi se formando foi pegando seus
caminhos ea gente resolveu terminar com
a banda foi tudo bloqueio teve porrada
nem nada e eu montei o félix e los
carozos quero félix ea sobra da pupunha
não é só a rapa da pupunha
quero jogar os e foi nesse momento que
estava começando a esquentar a banda que
eu recebi uma ligação do carlos eduardo
miranda que se foi recentemente para
produzir um trabalho da gaby amarantos
que até aquele momento não tinha nenhum
disco lançado discos nenhum disco solo
lançado ele falou cara do que é ser o
guitarrista dhabi
aí eu falo que quero mas ela quer que eu
seja a ele para fazer esse trabalho
bora ele estava na direção me chamou pra
produzir o disco eu que já conhecia a
gabi que uma daquelas bandas que
apareceu lá escrito era uma banda
chamada banda sarah que em 98 99 eu
toquei a gagueira cantora já conhecia
gabi de bandas bailes assim já tinha e
já estava vendo a evolução dela com a
tecnoshow
1 a banda quero mais é certa e depois de
carreira solo em 2010
eu comecei a produzir a gabi gente
produziu esse disco aí o treme né risco
deu bastante visibilidade para gabi a
gente é concorreu em duas categorias ao
grammy latino é ganhou outros prêmios e
com a gabi teve várias experiências sair
tocando lá no circo voador com zélia
duncan mart'nália a gente lá no encontro
que foi várias vezes no encontro com a
fernanda takai segue a e depois resolvi
sair da gabi
aí ficou agora em seu trabalho solo que
eu tava tamanho que é porque eu sei que
eu sou um cara inquieto e eu estava
pensando assim é preciso fazer meu
trabalho acabe já está consolidada com o
trabalho dela é preciso fazer meu
trabalho e foi quando caiu a ficha
mas cadê a cena musical cadeia de cena
musical de guitarrada cadeia à noite
na época eu sempre na época do apoio que
sempre fechou a noite sempre movimentou
a noite só estava muito fria não tinha
os mais lugares tocando guitarra etc
foi quando bateu o estalo defere-se
músico para félix e empreendedor porque
não bastava tocar
bastava eu ficar convidando as pessoas
para a festa tv tinha que criar um
produto e esse produto primeiro produto
que lancei foi a quinta radar que era
uma festa dia de quinta feira de
guitarrada num bar pequeno lá para o pé
da doca e isso foi chamando o público
chamando o público que foi insistindo
sempre vendendo a história de e dançar
música paraense de se divertir e essa
festa durou dois anos cerca de mais ou
menos 120 edições ininterruptas e
durante esse processo eu gravei o
primeiro disco que o equatorial quente
úmido que tem aquela música eu quero
cerveja e e isso vai ajudando muito
porque eu já estava com um público
formado com a festa e estava com o disco
cedido e música sendo tocada na festa as
pessoas me conhecendo conhecendo minhas
músicas e vendo que tinha um conteúdo
com conteúdo nisso aí
e 2016 eu gravei o segundo disco chamado
belém de bangcoc em cima de uma pesquisa
que eu fiz sobre a origem da lambada
sobre gêneros que deram origem à lambada
que esse nome lambada é uma gíria dada
por nós paraenses para músicas todos de
fora que tocavam ac e belém de benguí
nasceu essa festa linda bateria que eu
falo que foi um upgrade na na quinta
radar que está errada eu meio que
resolver as coisas sozinho mas só eu
nunca ia dar conta de resolver tudo foi
quando eu entrei em sociedade com essa
cidadã do meio que a sony a ferro que a
minha esposa e meus amigos équipe
cotejos é que nascimento conhecido como
zé que ficou termo dj e mudou tudo aí
eram três cabeças pensando três cabeças
tentando resolver uma coisa evoluiu uma
coisa e até agora nós fizemos 94 edições
de lã bateria e não vou dizer
interrompidas porque nós recentemente
trocou de lugar e interrompeu só uma
semana
das 94 edições e que a gente vende na
festa é diversão música é o brio de
ouvir música paraense de dançar e se
divertir tomando aquela cervejinha mas
sempre respeito com todo mundo que está
lá tem gente toda a cidade todas as
idades todos os gêneros e todas as
classes sociais sempre ingresso barato
tá com uma oportunidade de todo mundo
poderia toda a semana já que a festa
toda semana e sempre levando artistas
novos
e da festa saiu vários produtos assim
chá quente e fala vários eventos aqui
festival
lamba teria tenho-o o o playground que é
uma festa infantil que a gente faz
também o revellion dos lambadeiros natal
dos lambadeiros o baile da camisa
florida que é o nosso carnaval quem faz
e também temos nossos produtos
daí a nossa lojinha que vende a camisa
florida vencedores não só os meus cds
vendidos e de todos os artistas vende é
que o artista que quiser chegar lá
deixar o cd é só botar a gente vende
repassa o dinheiro pra eles
está assim é fã de camisa florida é de
onde vem a camisa florida né porque
sempre fala sempre vence negócio e vem
de cidadão aí o méxico vieira aí sou eu
do lado dele também é uma fase que eu
tenho até vergonha de mostrar sem barba
que num me acostumei me acostumo mais ou
sem barba e tv o méxico verde do lado um
disco de líquido de 80 e pouco que ele
está de camisa florida em frente de uma
aparelhagem já era um visionário né quem
sabe até onde aparelhagem a guitarrada
né
eu sempre curti camisa florida está aí o
meu priminho criança com as camisas
floridas né
háháhá a música pra mim sempre foi algo
que sempre foi visto como trabalho eu
tenho pai artista plástico que sempre me
ensinou a trabalhar com a arte ele é
artista plástico trabalha com a chi e
sempre falou meu filho você não pode só
ficar tocando
você precisa conhecer pessoas
você precisa se comunicar você precisa
fazer um produto é isso aí que o motor
mostrando pra vocês é exatamente isso
eu conheci pessoas
estudei um pouco me baseei um pouco pra
isso é é é o curso em uma faculdade não
terminei a faculdade que já estava
tocando muito não conseguia estar
viajando muito
eu fui fui reprovado mesmo assim dois
anos e eu eu eu tenho intenção de voltar
só pra questão de honra também tá e uma
coisa que eu sempre falo é a mais
pessoas que desistem porque pessoas
fracasso
eu descobri esses dias que é do henry
ford essa frase nem sabia que a dele mas
eu sempre falei porque você tem uma
idéia na sua cabeça se você aprimorar
essa idéia se você trabalhar direito é
tentar ver que não conseguiu tentar de
novo e dá mais quem trabalha com arte
eu trabalho com arte e eu tenho essa
oportunidade de errar e fazer de novo
nem toda profissão que tem essa
oportunidade como piloto de avião tem a
oportunidade de errar só uma vez né
eu posso errar e continuar de novo
entendeu e é isso que eu falo pra vocês
que dependendo da profissão que vocês
estão escolhendo quem está a tentar
fazer é tentar meter a cara não esperar
também fica totalmente preparado pra
começar que totalmente preparada
preparado a gente nunca vai ficar e às
vezes é tarde demais já está velho hoje
para o mercado de ficar velho é muito
rápido então a ideia é netão a cara
façam o que vocês gostam de fazer
mas quero falar com o pessoal falar
fazer o que a gente gosta é bom porque a
gente nem sente o trabalho quase isso
porque menos de fazer o que a gente
gosta tem coisas que pretende entrar no
mercado a gente precisa fazer e tem
coisas que a gente precisa
dá uma flexibilizada para poder fazer e
é isso que é a vida de artista também a
vida de artista é a vida como qualquer
outro outro profissional
a gente tem que vender nosso produto e
tem que pagar nossas contas
a gente se diverte lá tocando se diverte
mas se chegar no final do mesmo não dá
pra pagar as contas não vai aí vai
começar o choro nem vai acabar diversão
entendeu
era isso que eu queria falar pra vocês a
lição sobre sobre esse meu bate papo é
falar que é e dependentemente do caminho
que você escolher
você vai ter que ser empreendedor não tô
falando empresário naquela hora falei de
félix empreendedor empresário diferente
mesmo empresário só que deposita
dinheiro do que ele está ali ele está
ali no boca a boca no corpo-a-corpo
conversando tentando resolver as coisas
articulando sabe é botar a mão na massa
e é o que nós somos na bateria da eusec
a sônia entendeu e a profissão de vocês
vocês vão ter que ser um pouco artista
também vocês vão ter que dar uma
rebolada de vez em quando né
vocês vão ter que ser usados se vocês
vão ter que inventar algo diferente para
entrar no mercado e no nosso meio é a
mesma coisa quero agradecer a
oportunidade de vir aqui falar sem saber
que é bem rapidinho costumo falar pra
caramba mas pude dar lhes bater papo com
vocês e eu agradeço a atenção agradeço
ao ted povo te chamado para falar aqui
obrigado valeu
[Aplausos]